ouais
[Musique]
on connaissait netflix my canal ou
encore amazon prime il faudra maintenant
faire avec leur concurrent apple tv 10t
plus ou encore peacock
bienvenue dans un monde où les
plateformes vidéo se font la guerre
alors il va falloir choisir parce que
tous les français vont pas pouvoir
prendre un abonnement dans chaque maison
amazon ocs et puis maintenant disney
apple tv
on sait les géants américains qui
arrivent il n'arrive pas les mains vides
il faut quand même savoir que disney va
mettre 15 milliards de dollars par an
dans l'achat et la production de contenu
netflix fait déjà 15 milliards amazon en
mai 6 milliards apple va remettre 6
milliards nbc va en mettre à peu près
autant on n'a jamais vu autant d'argent
ça fait 50 milliards de dollars qui ont
été investis par an dans la production
de cbc
et pour bien comprendre cette guerre
ouverte
on a demandé un spécialiste du sujet de
nous dresser un état des lieux
en france le marché de la s vod a
toujours été très conflictuelle et ce
complice date pas d'hier il vient d'une
loi qui s'appelle la chronologie des
médias alors l'idée de cette loi vient
d'un constat super simple c'est le fait
que au tout début de la télévision en
france les utilisateurs peuvent pour la
première fois voir des films chez eux et
l'état voit un problème arrivait à
grands pas c'est la mort des acteurs
historiques dans ce cas là on parle des
cinémas du coup on évite les problèmes
et ont créé la chronologie des médias
qui est une loi qui régit à partir de
combien de temps un film peut être
diffusé en salles puis diffusée à la
télévision
très rapidement cette loi va être
surnommé loi canal+ par à peu près tout
le monde dans le pays puisqu'elle va
réunir principalement le temps de
diffusion des films à la télévision et
donc à la télévision cryptée et en
l'occurrence en france l'acteur
principal a toujours été canal+ mais
l'arrivée des plateformes de s vod en
france va bouleverser cette chronologie
des médias est l'acteur qui nous
intéresse dans ce cas là c'est netflix
qui est arrivé en france en 2014 et qui
va rendre totalement mainstream dans le
pays la consommation de films chez soi
ils vont faire ça assez facilement en
cassant les prix comme les acteurs
américains savent le faire dans une
économie de services
et le constat de la chronologie des
médias appliqué à la vod est claire les
gens ne peuvent pas voir un film qui est
sorti il ya moins de trois ans sur une
plateforme comme netflix et c'est là
qu'on arrive à la deuxième partie du
conflit l'arrivée de la concurrence dans
ce secteur très peu concurrentiel alors
la concurrence dans la s vod c'est
quelque chose auquel les américains
étaient tout à fait habitués ça fait
maintenant des années que sur des plates
formes comme par exemple où on va
retrouver beaucoup d'émissions télé et
de dessins animés des plateformes comme
s bio ont diffusé game of thrones
alors que pendant ce temps là en france
qu'on avait un combat à mort entre
canalplay et netflix et oui le temps
béni où il y avait quasiment tout sur
deux ou trois plateformes seulement est
maintenant révolue déjà amazon prime est
disponible en france depuis le 14
décembre 2016 est maintenant de nouveaux
acteurs puissants investissent le marché
le risque pour le consommateur c'est
tout simplement que les films les
documentaires ou les émissions se
retrouvent éparpillés sur une dizaine de
plateformes différentes pour lesquelles
il faudra à chaque fois payer un
abonnement nouveau et c'est notamment le
cas pour vous amateurs de séries télé
vous êtes particulièrement impacté par
la guerre des droits de
fusion alors la guerre des droits c'est
pas nouveau on a l'habitude maintenant
que netflix perdre les droits de série
ou de film quelques années après les
arts diffusé d'ailleurs il ya eu un cas
très intéressant à partir de l'arrivée
de netflix en france où on a vu netflix
naître capable de diffuser que la saison
4 de sa propre série phare house of
cards tout simplement parce que avant
son arrivée en france 9 x avait cédé les
droits de diffusion en france à canal+
mais avec l'arrivée en novembre de
disney plus on s'attaque à un tout autre
problème puisque disney promet de
rapatrier sur sa plateforme l'entièreté
des contenus dont elle avait jusque-là
cédé les droits
et quand on parle de disney on parle pas
simplement des dessins animés de votre
enfance on parle aussi de toutes les
acquisitions qu'ils ont fait ces
dernières années parce que disney c'est
aussi marvel star wars the walking dead
ou encore grey's anatomy disney possède
beaucoup plus de contenu et de sociétés
productrices de contenu qu'on pense et
ça risque de faire très mal à tous les
acteurs du milieu de plus disney possède
une force que n'ont pas ses concurrents
des programmes jeunesse qui vont lui
permettre de maintenir son nombre
d'abonnés
parce que oui les dessins animés pour
les enfants sont en première ligne dans
cette bataille
quand on a un modèle comme ça par
abonnement c'est très intéressant de
recruter des gens mais ce qui est encore
plus intéressant c'est de les conserver
et donc les programmes jeunesse sont
véritablement les programmes qui empêche
qu'on se désabonnent essayer quand vous
êtes abonné et que vos enfants regardent
leurs programmes jeunesse
essayez de vous désabonner c'est
absolument impossible à moins d'avoir un
drame familial
et au milieu de cette guerre de géants
internationaux
il y a les plateformes françaises my
canal pour l'historique canal+ et salto
pour nos bonnes vieilles chaînes de
télévision m6 tf1 et france télé ils
savent très bien qu'ils peuvent pas
rivaliser ils ont pas les moyens
le ticket moyen c'est quand même 6
milliards ou 1 8 milliard de dollars par
an ils ont pas les moyens
en revanche ils vont travailler avec
vous avez vu que canal+ a signé un
accord avec netflix et que tf1 et m6 co
produisent déjà des
ces vies avec notre vie que l'idée dans
l'esprit de à la fois du groupe canal et
de salto c'est de s'allier avec ses
plateformes et de faire en sorte que sur
les coproductions qu'ils fassent la
diffusion en france se fasse son salto
et mick hannah et il laisse le reste du
monde diffusée par les eaux troubles
beaucoup vont être sur des sujets locaux
ils veulent se démarquer comme ça des
plateformes des géants américains tels
que netflix qui programment une offre
mondialisé où tout le monde peut suivre
les séries américaines enfin s'est vu
dans le monde entier en france ils
veulent se démarquer avec des programmes
locaux ce qui est commun pour chaque
plateforme c'est que pour survivre et ne
pas disparaître
elles vont devoir attirer les
utilisateurs avec des prix très
attractifs mais vraiment très attractif
il ya la guerre des prix sur les
abonnements alors n'être fiq
aujourd'hui c'est un abonnement à 10
euros par mois
disney s'est positionné nettement en
dessous à 6 dollars à peu près et apple
a fait une annonce en disant ben nous on
va se positionner encore plus bas à
5 dollars donc il va y avoir
effectivement une un phénomène assez
étonnant c'est à dire que les prix vont
baisser
apple et disney pour moi ce sont des
offres de lancement dans un an ou deux
vous verrez ils s'aligneront sur netflix
netflix a déjà augmenté ses tarifs ya
pas très longtemps
donc moi je ne vois pas comment ils
peuvent perdurer s'ils n'augmentent pas
leurs offres
lors du touquet ce qui va se passer dans
les prochains mois et les prochaines
années suite à la sortie de disney plus
selon moi je pense qu'on va faire face à
un retour en beauté du piratage alors
que le piratage avait baissé ces
dernières années surtout avec l'arrivée
de netflix pour le cinéma de spotify
pour la musique et quel que soit le
domaine des offres légales à bas prix
l'arrivée rapide dans le secteur de très
gros concurrents qui se partagent des
droits va obligatoirement laisser les
utilisateurs sur le carreau parce que
personne n'a envie de s'abonner à 25
service de streaming pour suivre les
séries qu'ils ont envie de suivre et que
en séparant différentes formes de
contenu sur différentes plateformes
eh ben on rend l'offre illégale beaucoup
plus attractive beaucoup plus simple
d'accès où il ya deuxième réponse
il y aura peut-être des nouveaux acteurs
qui n'existe pas encore qu'ils savent
être des supers agrégateurs et qui vont
permettront avec un seul et unique
compte qui sera un procès
je ne sais pas vingtaine ou trentaine de
dollars de pouvoir jongler à l'intérieur
avec vos différents abonnements d'être
sûr d'être sur spotify puis passer sur
apple musée goût d'être sur netflix
longs mois d'octobre et puis de passer
sur amazon mois de novembre et puis de
d'aller sur disney au mois de décembre
c'est un métier qui devrait se
développer et en attendant le mois
dernier envoi possible les plateformes
pourraient se tourner vers les
fournisseurs d'accès comme ils le font
aux états unis pour proposer des offres
couplées
on pourrait par exemple s'abonner chez
bouygues telecom et recevoir un
abonnement netflix ou disney plus mais
est-ce que ça va suffire est ce que les
prix resteront suffisamment attractif
pour garder la basse ça reste à voir
[Musique]